[Musique]
la sénatrice et présidente du
département nassimah dindar et
l'ensemble des élus se sont réunis en
séance plénière ce mercredi 18 novembre
dans l'hémicycle du palais de la source
six rapports ont été votés parmi eux
celui du financement de label agricole
bio en faveur des produits pays
nous avons décidé de porter l'aide aux
agriculteurs biologiques en augmentant
la participation du département sur la
certification qui leur est nécessaire
pour être reconnu comme agriculteur
biologique on passe de 250 à 600 euros
le prix de la certification nous payons
à 100% pour les encourager et les aider
à maintenir le dispositif de
d'agriculteurs biologiques et puis nous
avons voté la participation du
département un fonds de garantie qui a
été confiée à la solidaire c'est une un
dispositif important qui vont aider les
pas des petits porteurs de projets à se
lancer dans leurs opérations et obtenir
toutes les garanties financières
nécessaires pour pouvoir lancer donc
leur activité autre sujet phare de cette
assemblée la décision modificative qui
vise à ajuster le budget départemental
au regard des notifications de recettes
et de l'avancement des projets en cours
nous avons examiné la situation
financière du département sa fin d'année
à travers une décision modificative et
le point important qui est ressorti
devons dire c'est que la situation
financière du département malgré les
contraintes nous avons réussir parce que
nous avons fait des efforts de bonne
gestion nous avons réussi à réduire
notre endettement de près de 17 juillet
une des dernières séances plénières pour
nassimah dindar en tant que président du
département
prochaine étape la cimenterie se
présentera lors de son départ son bilan
de gestion de 2004 à 2010 est l'occasion
sera donnée aussi de présenter au fond
mon bilan de gestion de l'argent public
parce que c'est important quand on voit
tout ce qui est mis dans les journaux
comment la présidente du département
comment nous avons géré et comment moi
j'ai géré de 2004 à 2010 est l'argent
public est ce que je les fais en bonne
mère de famille ou pas j'aurai
l'occasion de le présenter
chiffres à l'appui lors de mon départ
[Musique]